[Music]
all right
hello hello hello and welcome this is
wisdom for life and I
your co-host uh Dan Hayes and we have
our illustrious other co-host Mr Dr Greg
Sadler and today we're having a lovely
little story and a show about setting
boundaries and sticking to them
hopefully calmly
we won't get too upset with each other
unless you stray over into my time
right
um so uh any opening thoughts here uh
Greg
yeah this is one of those things that a
lot of people struggle quite a bit with
and I'll say that I myself have
struggled with it quite a quite a bit in
the past how do you set and maintain
healthy boundaries with other people who
may try to get over on you or maybe
taking more than their fair share or
sometimes just don't know that they're
doing things that are negatively
impacting you how do you do that without
say
appealing to anger as the motivator to
do that which which is not a very
healthy way to set boundaries and then
we can think of there's a lot of other
topics we can think of as well like how
do you set boundaries when you're doing
it on the behalf of other people
um you know what counts as healthy
boundaries some people seem to be a
little bit
selfish or egocentric when it comes to
that boundaries for them but no
boundaries for anybody else so there's a
whole host of topics wrapped up in this
but you have a particular lens that you
thought would be really helpful to
examine this through right uh yes it's
uh we're gonna for the most part kind of
look at this through the idea of stoic
action and I'll get to that in just a
moment but I did want to expand on that
you know we're going to talk a little
bit also about
setting boundaries for yourself as well
and the difference between that and uh
the external boundaries that we set for
other people and
also the the way in which we actually do
this the modes of setting boundaries
uh but yeah uh within
um stoicism there's uh three major
uh disciplines and that of ascent action
and desire
and uh the main thing we're going to be
talking about here is is stoic action
and uh
actually acting out the things that are
you know either virtuous or moral
um but this is also based in the idea of
what do you actually desire and what you
accept to be true and so uh that is your
ascending or accepting of the the world
around us as well as uh the desire of
things that are actually under our
control and not Desiring those things
that are not under our control
yeah and so the the three disciplines
that you're talking about Epictetus is
the the place that we go his his
discourses for hearing about them but it
seems like he didn't come up with these
this is something that was a
well-established idea in stoicism and
since we just don't have that many stoic
texts that's the place that we we go so
though I'll ask you a question but but
first I just want to clarify for our
listeners that when we're talking about
these disciplines these are things that
you could think of as fields of study
and and and the word that we translate
as discipline is actually topos which
which does mean a field that you would
engage in study of and that would
transform you as a person and so the
field of action it also includes the
study of choice so that we can learn how
to make choices better and prioritize
sometimes we can't have everything that
we would like to have and we have to
choose between different uh different
Goods or uh to have you know we have to
figure out what's the the worst evil so
we can avoid
if you do let me know because you would
be the first person I ever met who did
but yeah we and and that's I mean you're
you're talking about setting limits for
yourself I think that's something we
should come back to as as well we we
can't have it all so we actually do have
to set limits to ourselves as human
beings
um but the other thing I wanted to say
with the discipline of action is
Epictetus says this involves our duties
or moral obligations the things that we
we owe to other people and and we could
even say oh to ourselves so the things
that another way of translating duties
is appropriate actions the actions that
are called for and I think we'll spend a
good bit of time talking about how that
fits in with setting boundaries as well
um so
you know how how do how does this
discipline help us to
identify what good boundaries are and
then set the boundaries and then stick
with them what do you think
uh well
first I guess I I want to Define
boundaries a little bit and I found a
really interesting quote from Aristotle
about defining boundaries of a thing as
the first point Beyond which is not
possible to find any part of X or the
thing and the first point within which
every part of the thing is
yeah but
it's a little bit more intuitively for
physical objects but is definitely still
applicable within this that you have a
certain you know especially uh
interpersonal uh lines in which that you
are going to Define your behavior by
yeah and
so if if you do that I mean let's
consider an example what what's a case
in which somebody has to set a boundary
uh for another person to observe that
maybe transgressing that boundary
um conversation right uh you know
somebody here's a great example you ever
had the kind of person who when you tell
a story they've always got a better
story and they tell it immediately after
yours so like you went I don't know on a
vacation to uh some little place and
then they went to a bed and breakfast
that was even better than the bed and
breakfast that you actually and so you
you recognize this Dynamic and then
after a while you're like hey man when
you're taught when I'm talking uh I'm
telling a story you keep on jumping in
and undermining my story I don't like
that so now you're setting a boundary
right and so now how do you make the
boundary clear to them you say when when
I'm talking about something I would
really like if maybe if you've done
something similar you just like keep
that to yourself for the time being or
maybe only do it one time out of three
because what you're doing right now is
really getting on my nerves it almost
seems deliberate on your part so how how
would that fit in with this this limit
thing what would what would be the stuff
that's on one side and the stuff that's
on the other side would it be like
appropriate behavior is on one side and
inappropriate behaviors on the other
side of the boundary
yeah and I think
maybe it's uh easier to use an example
where there's like a really clear
demarcation because within this uh
particular example it is not always
clear you know it requires a multitude
of instances to Define that that is
actually a problem whereas
um you know they're I guess easier for
certain topics that are just kind of
taboo to talk about so in polite company
usually there's the idea of what money
politics and religion don't talk about
them you know that I guess that changes
for some people but there's definitely
like uh you know you're not going to
talk about
um
with regular company like uh one's uh
intimate details of their sex life that
just is uh and so that's a really bright
line so we can move back from that but
that is at least a a things like yes um
I don't want to talk about that and uh
it would be a point where it was like
you know
um either say the person I'd rather not
talk about that or just remove yourself
from that conversation
so we could say that there's multiple
kinds of limits or boundaries right we
could say there are those that are
pretty clear-cut and sometimes people
still don't observe them or they may
have grown up in circumstances that tell
them that that's not that really a
boundary people don't really care about
that until they run into people who do
so we could call those like I think you
said brightline
um yeah okay well let's call them bright
line boundaries that that sounds pretty
good and then we've got the ones that
are a little bit more fuzzy and
negotiable and require
some extra attentiveness perhaps or a
sense of proportion or Prudence where
it's tougher because like you said where
where does the line lie you know that
something is being done that's going too
far but being able to say precisely
where that border lies is is a bit
tricky
effort example the of the
non-conversational well I guess it still
partly conversational I had a a long
discussion with a gentleman on and he
and I had a really different
um ideas of what personal space were oh
that's a good example yeah and I I just
constantly was unconsciously backing up
in order to try to maintain my personal
space that I find comfortable with
especially as this gentleman was
probably a foot taller than me so he was
also looming and so that made it you
know I'm I'm gawking up to actually uh
keep him in full View and and try to
maintain the conversation but he would
always move closer to me every time that
I'd move back and we had this like
little slow unconscious ballet around
the room that we were in on it trying to
find what we would find as a enjoyable
uh distance in order to get him to and
you know yeah at this point in time
um I I could really have a good cudgel
to say hey we should say six feet back
about and having a good agreement but
like that is
um one of those things where you can say
to your uh partner in there that you
know this is a boundary I would like to
uh get and
um if I I guess I was unconscious of at
the time and I really had in reflection
hope or wish that I had actually done
something about it but
um or at least made it a point because I
did put on myself being uncomfortable in
that position and if we're trying to
have a good and productive conversation
then that is undermining that outcome
yeah and so we can talk about modalities
of boundaries in in your case
that was uh about physical space
proxemics right and but it also impinged
on
on conversation
um and so you know we could talk about
like crossing boundaries in terms of
getting too close to people or
um doing other things physically that
that they they don't want you to do or
are inappropriate and then we've got
what people say and what else would be
other examples of crossing boundaries or
other other types of crossing boundaries
I mean we can talk about financial
boundaries couples get into this sort of
problem all the time and so do business
partners where one person makes
decisions and then doesn't clear it with
the other person and you know it leads
to a lot of uh Rancor or they could have
different priorities and and what
they're they're thinking about their
finances so that could be another area
what else would be modalities uh I think
that there's really two big categories
of modality which are those things that
you can do for yourself and and it
doesn't require you to actually interact
with anyone else and those things that
require you to interact with someone
else so Cooperative action yeah so for
example like you know if if I'm finding
a conversation to be very negative I
have the two choices or maybe more but
like in this
um of the the two major modalities I'm
talking about there's one I can just
remove myself in the conversation and
say I don't need to be here anymore and
I can just leave or the second one is to
um
interact with the person that you're
finding that is uh infringing on you
know some sort of uh level of
um correct action in this point in order
to try to modify their action so to
steer like say a conversation in in a
better direction right yeah or or tell
the guy please step back I know I do
that sometimes in conversations be at
events with um audience members or with
uh
students like in a class if I have
somebody who wants to try to take take
over they've got an agenda and they
don't want to discuss what it was that
we were discussing you know for example
if I'm talking about existentialism they
want to talk about I don't know you know
mac and cheese and other different kinds
of it I can I can usually find ways to
sort of Corral them and and bring the
conversation back to what it is that
we're focused on and I'll say quite
often well you know listen we're here to
talk about X so is that is that a way of
setting a boundary then or rather
maintaining a boundary I suppose right
well yeah also it's you know goes into
relationships and you know are a lot of
our boundaries are set by the type of
relationships that we have and so for
example you are a professor and you have
a everyone at the classes essentially
there for a particular reason to learn
the material that is being presented by
you you would hope that is the case yes
but but that that's at least if you ask
people like what is the point of being
here I find that it'd be very difficult
for someone to especially if they're
paying for it uh to not
that's that's an interesting approach
that I I haven't being that direct and
saying what what exactly are we doing
here and does what you're doing fit into
that
function and I suppose you could apply
that in other like in a business meeting
for example if somebody wants to spend
you know you've allotted 50 minutes on
the calendar for it and and you see that
this person is just like chattering on
and on about War Stories and their ideas
about this and that and they've taken up
like 15 minutes so you could like maybe
bring them back to the agenda right
uh what's the rule that um uh the
contents of a meeting will expand to the
length of the meeting to find that's
true yeah
and in our own time we are indeed
finding that there are many meetings
that could have been emails right uh and
that's that's another one I I get you
know people emailing me about quite a
few things uh not least because I'm
editor stosus today and so I get a lot
of people who want to try to get their
stuff into stoicism today and I'll tell
them you know we accept things that are
here's like the minimum length here's
the maximum length it's got to really
deal with stoicism because the
readership is interested in in that and
I do get you know quite a few people who
are just pitching me content because
they want to get their stuff out there
anywhere and there's some put I have to
do pushback you know I have to say well
it's not going into the the online
Journal because you're not fulfilling
these these requirements I'd be happy to
see you you know do that and that would
be really great and I would say like
three times out of four and they don't
they don't do it they you know they
abandon the effort but then I do get
some who will you know jump through the
proverbial Hoops
um which aren't just you know it's not
just making somebody dance around for
the sake of doing that it's it's to try
to produce a good result for the the
readership of the journal uh to provide
them with something that that tells them
something new about how to apply
stoicism
um another actually that so that leads
me to another question
when we're laying down boundaries do we
need to should we look at them as like
well I've set down a boundary it's there
um you know fences have their own sort
of rationale to them hands off back off
you know you have to observe this or
should we should we be focused on what
the good the purpose the end of setting
the boundary is or does it vary from
case to case do you think
I think for the most part I would go to
the ends so the Talos the what is it
actually producing you know so if if you
just set down a boundary and just say
well that's my boundary and I'm sticking
to it regardless and the boundaries
results in really bad outcomes with the
outcomes that you weren't expecting yeah
then it takes it's a time to reassess
those boundaries
and you can only do that in terms of
what the point is about is all right
right I guess I
like what what are examples of the the
other position like uh well countries
boundaries or no I was thinking that in
some cases maybe in like specific
situations you don't want to be like
bringing up to mine well what was the
whole point of this in the first place
you want to be able to maintain some of
these fairly automatically so so for
example you know in in our time of uh
covid and social distancing if I go
outside I'm walking the dog and somebody
wants to come up to me to chat and
they're you know coming more than uh
they're coming closer than six feet I
shouldn't have to like think out okay
what was the point of this boundary
before I should just maybe say to them
hey back up you know you need to get
away you need to you need to move back
to at least six feet away and and so I
think maybe our routine boundaries maybe
some of them should be more
um deontological in the way that we
approach them where we say oh the rule
is the rule and then when we get into
sticky situations where like you said it
could produce bad effects
um maybe then we need to reassess and
and I think that in a lot of cases where
where we are willing to reassess we
could also be taken advantage of people
who are like well if you'd accept this
that you'd also accept this there's
there's people who do want to for
whatever reason violate other people's
boundaries and if they if they can get
them into conversation one of the one of
the ways in which they do succeed in
violating boundaries action boundaries
we might say physical boundaries is by
talking them into not standing up for
themselves
so so uh maybe in some cases we we
wouldn't want to do that
reminds me of how Jon Stewart Mill talks
about utilitarianism to a certain extent
and that you know we we can like
kind of formulate out to try to see what
results in the the most good for the
most people
um but if we're constantly trying to do
these calculations in every step of our
lives and we're never going to be able
to actually live our lives in the first
place and so uh he proposes okay for
um most things that like people will
come up to on a daily basis we should
probably have someone a group of people
that like look at these and like oh make
a rule and you know that make a
deontological you know a rule base for
for most situations and we don't just
have it at hand we don't have to be
thinking about all the time yeah and
and for those things that get really
tricky that's the only time that you
would actually sit down and contemplate
that and so in order to actually live
life in a a general way it does seem
that we need a a set of rules but the
idea is to not hold those rules as Dogma
that if if we're finding that they're
not working that there is a a time of
contemplation
yeah I suppose we could also say if if
following our rules leads to
being kind of selfish or Cavalier or
disregarding of other people's
legitimate boundaries
then we would have uh we'd have to
reconsider them as well right we say
maybe I don't need to protect myself
which is what boundaries really are
about is is maintaining
um some limits so that the the self
isn't isn't being taken advantage of or
damaged or exploited right
um in in the old-fashioned way of
talking about it so that you're not
being forced into suffering Injustice
um but maybe sometimes if we insist too
much on our maintaining our boundaries
we end up violating other people's
boundary
so we'd have to think think carefully
about that and actually that's sort of a
good segue into you you know you brought
up roles and responsibilities and
relationships before so I think for for
most people
are um
our boundaries and our expectations are
really set in the way that Epictetus
said where you know if we look at the
names of our our relationships we can
kind of see what we're supposed to be
doing and what other people are supposed
to be doing for us and he does recognize
that a lot of people fail at those
things
um so you know if we think about like
friends for example what what are
friends actually owe each other a lot of
times friends will kind of mess with
each other right play practical jokes
which can sometimes be quite bad maybe
they're not really friends if they're
willing to to go too far or they say
embarrassing things to each other but
that also seems to be a little bit of
the intimacy at all I'll give you a
funny example my sister and I
used to joke with each other in a way
that would seem quite mean from the
outside but we didn't intend it in a
mean way we were both adopted from
different families and we would we would
sometimes tell each other uh mom likes
me more because you're adopted
and now it's somebody else looking at
that from the outside that looks like
like we're crossing a line right why
would you say that to somebody and and
for us it was okay within that that
framework although I would never say
that to somebody else
um because I wouldn't want to hurt their
feelings and and we could do that
because we knew it wasn't going to hurt
our feelings so
maybe maybe relationships are the most
important place we set up
so
Seneca the younger has some ideas within
his discourses to lasilius
um about what is a friend and he is
admonishing lucilius
um saying like there's this guy and you
call him your friend but you've just
barely met him then and he has a very
high standard for what a friend is and
um Seneca says that a friend as a
unvetered confidant that someone that
you can trust implicitly
because the the his ideas a friend
should be someone that you can tell your
innermost thoughts to in order to get
the best counsel
um about what you should do
um and and you can only give a good
counsel when you have all the
information and
um you know you want to be open to them
as much as you are to yourself
um without complete Candor you will not
get the best counsel
uh
do you feel like that's a good
um definition of a friend or
you know
that so that's that's kind of a tough I
would say that's that's a really good
threat right
um and
we we use this term friend very very
Loosely so you know we've got Facebook
friends who maybe we don't know from
Adam they're like connections uh
LinkedIn is better Call just calling
people connections you know our Twitter
with followers
um
and then we have like you know people
that we talk about as being friends but
we're not really friends with them we
just kind of know them if we were
pushing it we'd say they're
acquaintances or neighbors or
uh people like that but we do feel some
sort of connection and perhaps even
affection towards them or or obligations
towards them right so there's you know
it's not as if I kind of look at
friendship as not being like an on off
switch but rather a continuum
and you know we've got a couple classic
treatments of it like Aristotle has has
two you know hold books devoted to
Friendship in the nick of McCain ethics
Cicero has an entire book called on
friendship and then Seneca has these
letters and there's many other
treatments of friendship running
throughout
um the the the interesting literature on
what it's about and and they do talk
about like what we might call the
epitome of friendship and I think that's
what Seneca is after there a really
really good friend somebody who you're
going to be friends with for good
provided they don't change in their
character and turn into you know an
awful person is somebody who you'd want
to have as a confidante somebody as a
counselor right
um some Aristotle actually talks about
friends sharing uh not just information
with each other or habits but sharing
Joys and Sorrows so you know the person
that you would go to
like after a death in the family and
they'll commiserate with you but you
could also ask them wow now I gotta
handle this estate how do I do this you
know
um I think that that that would be sort
of what he's talking about and in a very
close relationship like that you know
it's you would think that there wouldn't
have to be setting bound but there
probably is just because we're such
messy creatures as human beings right so
there are going to be inevitably things
where
um we we managed to step on each other's
Toes or push each other's buttons
whatever metaphor you you like and then
and then then the question is well how
do good people
how do they respond in order to say hey
this this you you cross the line I don't
want you to do this uh without getting
into all the other things that that
people often bring in like shouting at
each other getting angry holding grudges
um being passive aggressive about it you
know
um those I think those are are key as
well and and hopefully when you've got
genuinely good people
if they don't do none of that they'll do
less of it but what about the rest of us
who aren't genuinely good people who are
just sort of on the way at best you know
I guess the whole idea of practice and
not you know having a binary of good or
evil and we're not and I don't think
anyone is like the pure good or the pure
best you know we're we're all have the
ability to uh foul up and uh not be that
best friend
oh you know that's actually a good
example too when we let our friends down
um we often
you know we we've transgressed some sort
of expectation I don't know if we want
to call it a limit or a boundary but we
we've failed in some way and then you
know we don't want that to become a
practice so they would be perfectly
right to say hey I'm going to cut you
some slack and forgive you this time but
don't let it happen again
um that then it would be laying down a
boundary right yeah yeah and and
communication is very key in maintaining
these relationships if you're feeling
like your boundaries are constantly
being violated but you don't actually
articulate that your boundaries are
being violated then you're just going to
become more and more incensed at these
you know boundaries that you're holding
for yourself but are not actually uh
doing anything to maintain them yeah so
let's let's talk about when somebody is
trying to
set or maintain or call somebody's
attention to to a boundary what are the
good ways to do it and what are the the
bad ways to do it and why are they why
are they good why are they bad
I guess that comes down to uh at least
to portion your emotional outside or um
mindset in any of these situations so if
you you you sometimes people have this
misunderstood conception that I have to
get angry in order to
um motivate me to do something and so a
lot of people will be be passive
aggressive at because they they
haven't gotten they haven't figured out
a way to try to set these boundaries
without getting angry
um in order to set them and so they'll
like kind of see then they'll they'll do
little things that are are
slights against the other and the and
the idea is to try to you know look at
this as
um without that angry lens to uh say I
need to know how to
um calmly uh react to these situations
without letting my emotions get the
better of me in the situation
you know it's interesting
you bring up anger and I think there
could be other emotions but anger is
probably the biggest one involved in
this pushing back right
I I have a lot of people that I've seen
when I push back and I'm not angry and I
know the difference between when I am
angry and when I'm not because I do
struggle with anger
um and I there'll be plenty of times
where I'm pushing back like in the
properly stoic way where I see that it's
the right thing to do and practical
reason says hey uh say something to this
person I'm not actually angry and they
interpret me as being angry now
sometimes it's on the internet right so
like somebody like for example people
will like leave a comment on a video and
I'll be like well no you're wrong about
that
um here's what Aristotle actually says
and they'll be like why so angry bro and
I'll be like now there's the sign of
somebody who doesn't actually understand
limits either that or they're just kind
of playing around because they must
think that you can't like push back
unless you're angry otherwise they
wouldn't read it in to what other people
are doing and they'll or they'll say
things like why are you taking offense
you know uh which which is closely
connected and women run into this
problem more more than men do right if
they push back they often get
interpreted as being mean or angry or
cynical or whatever it is I mean that
could happen to men as well but it's
definitely a problem on the internet in
the workplace and I think also in in
relationship
and I think this comes to the idea of
like consistency is key within your
boundaries and okay if uh if the only
time that people are seeing people
setting up boundaries is when they are
angry then they do make this connection
this this false connection but if you
work to try to identify your boundaries
and to uh calmly uh State them on maybe
even really early on in a relationship
of like what you were expecting then it
it reduces that like potential
um negative response from someone uh
looking at the boundary because uh if if
you're going into it with a really
aggressive angry stance that puts your
other person into a on their back foot
into a really defensive you finally
crossed the line and now I'm gonna go
all Hulk on you that sort of yeah
um and and maybe part of it is just like
we need to have experiences where people
are setting you know mild boundaries and
and doing them in a really calm manner
in order to uh build up that expectation
of how we should be interacting with
people you know that I think that's a
great point and it's really interesting
that you talk about doing that early on
in a relationship because I think that
quite a few people
when they approach relationships
particularly like say romantic
relationships or friendships
um they seem to think that if you're
doing that if you're like saying well I
I prefer this and I don't like when you
do this that you're being controlling
you're like you know you're not allowing
for the spontaneity of things to develop
as they would say organically and but
what I mean you're right it's the best
thing to do is to establish boundaries
early often and consistently so that at
least you've got some some sort of basis
later on right
um so why do you think people view that
in in a negative
like that as being controller I guess
part of it I think is connected with the
idea that
there are people that have like
boundaries and they they're not open for
discussion and I think there's
definitely boundaries that are not open
for discussion but if you're going
forward with a new relationship
especially a romantic relationship
um that I've think that it would be good
to have some sort of
um connection
um or a place for discussion about these
boundaries that like okay these are my
boundaries that I would like and see if
there's any conflict with what the other
person is expecting and
um you know uh infidelity for many
people is is a deal breaker that's just
not something you're gonna get past in
that type of a relationship
um but it might be for someone but you
know where where do you actually have
that discussion and if you if you're not
open and honest with your discussion
about things then you can never actually
uh investigate them
yeah and this is again where I think
some practices from stoicism and other
virtue ethics approaches could be useful
we talked about this practice early on
in one of our episodes about we could we
could call it not assuming right uh
technically it's it's not allowing uh
yourself to be carried away by
Impressions or appearances you have to
stop and question them and say are you
really what you appear to be so imagine
that you're early on in a relationship
and you you're you're you know you're
somebody who's been hurt before and the
person that you're in the relationship
has been hurt before and you bring up
this issue of infidelity and now they
could say well why are you bringing that
up you must be bringing that up because
you want to cheat or you think I'm gonna
cheat or and all those sorts of
automatic inferences those are what get
us in trouble a lot of the time right
um so so this well we won't talk about
that and I think actually there's quite
a two relationships where there's what
they call landmines you know you know
well we're not going to talk about that
subject we're not going to talk about
that subject and you know I think some
people actually kind of like that but
most people don't and it makes for
things feeling kind of restricted and
restrained unreasonably and it stands in
the way of intimacy or a friendship or
whatever we're going to to talk about
um
I was thinking of like talking about a
lot we've been talking about has to do
with like our relationships with other
people but I think we should also really
talk about
um how we set moral standards or or
um for ourselves and how are we going to
set those boundaries about what we will
do and won't do
um for ourselves and I guess to grab
into the Friendship a little bit like
yeah um if you were friendly and loyal
to someone
um does that what is your reaction to
when they ask you to do something that
might be immoral or vicious you know
where where are your lines in comparison
to the relationships that you have uh
can what you have to choose which one
that you're going to Value more
yeah and you know I think sometimes the
advice that people like Cicero give are
are helpful
for example an on-friendship he says
well a real friend is never going to ask
you to do anything that's shameful or
moral or you know unjust and then you
can say well okay that's that's great so
now I know that this person isn't a real
friend but I still do need to like hold
on to this relationship so what do I do
sister Roy
um and and and uh I think he's he's
willing to say well in a lot of cases
you just got to walk away or be be
prepared to walk away and it you know
it's interesting so there's a bit of a
tangent but in in uh business
negotiations
I mean I've noticed this and a lot of
other people have written about this the
the very fact that you're willing to say
even though this is going to be a
sacrifice for me I'm going to
end this relationship and walk away from
say a deal or you know leave a job or uh
fire somebody or something like that
um will quite often lead to people not
pushing and saying oh boy they're taking
this seriously I'd better get my act in
gear and figure out how to how to make
this right
um and which which isn't to say that we
want to engage in a kind of
brinksmanship for its own sake
um
you know we could even talk about limits
on that maybe maybe you only get to pull
that that hey I'm gonna walk away if you
do this every once in a while or maybe
only once in a relationship but the
willingness to say I'm not going to
cooperate
is very important and to go back to the
point that you were talking about limits
for yourself
those are the limits that I think you
would really need to have set out before
you get into the situation so maybe
something like negative visualization
applied to relationships would be
important as well yeah
and
especially when we're talking about like
family and you know we're talking about
Cicero and their friends and like you
can walk away from your friend but it
becomes even more difficult when there's
um a family member asking you to do
something that might you consider me
vicious or immoral yeah in this sense
because you've got that even stronger
tie usually and then usually to disrupt
that time means disrupting ties within
the larger family too correct and so
like you you really need to you know as
you said negative visualization look at
like
what your family could ask you to do
that you would regularly consider a
moral and would you do that for the sake
of your family
yeah
so that leads into something that we're
thinking about talking about in in this
particular time social distancing and
quarantine and you know hand washing and
all these sorts of things that were
supposed to be all observing or wearing
masks as another prep example
um these are all in some respect kind of
physical about limits you know we we
wear a mask so that we're not breathing
uh in in things that other people are
and we're not subjecting them to to
whatever it is that we might be exhaling
we're saying stay six feet apart I mean
some people are saying stay further than
that uh but but that's the the
recommendation by going into you know
quarantine or whatever we want to call
it isolation we're separating ourselves
off from others
um you know not opening doors things
like that
um we've got all of that going on on top
of the usual stuff of having to maintain
normal boundaries psychologically in
action in words uh and all these these
other ways as well so I think there's
there's some new problems that are being
posed right because what if you live in
a household where one person doesn't
want to
follow the rules
um what do you do with in that case you
know it now it's no longer just a matter
of say one's own psychological Health it
also has to do with physical health as
well
and so this I'd say it goes back to that
like
stoic uh discipline of action and and at
this point in time like there's there's
not the ability for you to just remove
yourself from the situation you need to
go and act in order to try to uh bring
about a better outcome because it is the
the just thing to do to uh you know just
as the idea of like what people uh
treating people how they uh should be
treated and uh if especially if
someone's like immune compromised in
your family that
um you know your actions are directly
impacting the uh potential health of
someone that you live with and uh
because you have this obligation to each
other in that you're cohabitating
um that means that to a certain extent
all of your Fates are connected
especially through health and that you
are are forced in that instance to X
expand the idea of what your actions are
actually impacting not just your own you
are not a an individual actor here so in
setting down limits to other people say
getting too close to you you are also
maintaining limits for for other people
as well who you know may not be there in
the room but maybe sharing the same
space with you later on right
yeah so
I think you're right in talking about
this as a matter of Justice and
you know another idea that that this
made me think of and we'll have to do a
little bit of unpacking of this because
it's a technical term is oikosis which
um literally means like becoming
neighbors or becoming you know uh too
appropriate yeah yeah with with other
people and the stoics talked about these
these circles you know the most intimate
circle is us and our close friends and
family and then we have our neighbors
and then we have the people that are in
the same political Community as us and
then ultimately it goes out to the whole
human species and I mean it's similar to
I mean you talked quite a bit in the
past about Buddhist metamedication that
you see the connections between these as
well so maybe that would be a good thing
to bring up here but so the stoic idea
is that we should you know the the
things that we feel towards those who
we're close to we can extend that
feeling outwards to other people who we
don't already have that affection
towards and their by behave in a way
that's just worth them which would
include you know maintaining these these
uh these requirements of Health like
wearing a mask social distancing so by
by doing that I'm not just maintaining
limits for myself or my close family I'm
also doing it for the neighbor who I
don't know down the hall who uh I'm not
messing things up for or the you know
fellow citizens of Milwaukee in our case
um who we don't know right yeah and I
think that like
because we are social creatures and uh
for most people people will you know oh
what is the crowd doing
and and oh there's like what the Tipping
Point ten percent I think you know if
you can get 10 of the population to do
something it becomes like okay it's okay
for me to actually go and do that itself
and so yeah the more people that you see
like wearing masks and and maintaining
social distancing the more it becomes a
norm that can be accepted without the uh
the fear of being I guess oscar-sized or
something interesting yeah but this
comes back to
um our discipline of desire and are you
Desiring that uh you have a reputation
uh of anything but that's not in your
control it also brings up another virtue
that of courage or fortitude right
because to do the right thing to to
maintain the boundary that we should for
the sake of Health
um like wearing a mask when I when I
take uh my dog out for you know the
three times a daily walk I see very very
few people wearing masks I wear a mask
because I know that it's the right thing
for me to do for myself but even more so
for my wife who's in the same building
as me and perhaps who knows what my
other neighbors are doing we have we
have people who are in their 70s living
in our building and I see very few other
people doing it
um but I know it's the right thing to do
and so on so I do it I don't have any
problem myself with with that but I
could imagine that you know say a 20
year old uh who's more swayed by public
opinion at not wanting to be uncool or
something like that you know they would
need fortitude in order to do the right
thing and uh so that that virtue is is
particularly important as well not just
Justice
very good point
so what about what should people do
who live in
a building or are in a household with
other members who are not say staying
staying in I I read an interesting thing
where there was a woman who talked about
her husband
um and you know he has this drinks with
his golf buddies uh outside and then
invites them into the house and she's
like what are you doing you know and
you're bringing in people who could be
sick we don't know whether they're
carriers or not he's like well they're
my friends and so then she's faced with
this this quandary
um what should I do with this guy and
and she even asked should I be upset and
I think the answer is
yes she should be upset in the sense
that you know it was wrong for her
husband to do that
um she doesn't necessarily have to get
you know irate and angry and like say
burn all of his clothes or you know
start shouting or something like that
but the the appropriate response on her
part would be to say well if you don't
value your health and and you think that
hanging out with your buddies is more
important than our health I guess you
gotta sleep in the guest room and and
you know use use this doorway and you're
not coming in the kitchen and you better
figure out some bathroom Arrangements uh
because you're not using this one
hopefully they have two bathrooms in
their house or something like that I I
think that would be the right thing for
her to do in a case like that or and I
saw another case where somebody was
talking about her her son who was in his
20s and he kept going out and she was
like listen you know we're we're taking
this seriously you're not you're gonna
have to find another place to stay you
want to hang out with your friends
you're going to have to go hang out with
with them
um so you know I mean what do you think
about cases like that
I I absolutely agree that like you know
trying to explain to them I think maybe
uh rhetoric comes in here and that you
need to figure out what the best
argument that needs to be presented in
order for someone to actually understand
this and so uh maybe a logical argument
is the thing that will work maybe it's
not maybe it's the um uh
a uh uh a morality yeah a building
motion uh you know
um do you I don't know you want to say
you're the sons and it's like you know
do you want does your mom die or
something you know yeah that that's a
little bit I don't know
in the right situations it might be
necessary for like things that are life
and death you know
um
I think it is actually an appropriate
time to actually use this thing
um because maybe it's like the idea of
what is the actual risks here it isn't
actually properly understood until you
actually to think about the uh the
possible consequences and if you can get
someone to have an emotional response
that is a a really negative uh response
to the consequences of their actions
that might be the thing that will
convince them to change their actions
sort of like a Tipping Point for them
yeah you know
um do you think that the language that
you use is particularly important like
should it should when we're talking
about maintaining boundaries should we
call it boundaries we'll say listen I
have a hard boundary and it's this or is
is there are there better ways to to
express it is boundary more of a
technical term that maybe we wouldn't
want to use and we'd want to say like
I don't why as we people do an
assertiveness training I don't like when
you do X because it it does this to me
um I'd like you to stop doing is is that
a better way to establish
I guess it depends on the person that
you're interacting with uh you know for
some people the the I statements would
work especially if they value you as a
person and they want they want to
maintain that relationship that's very
good
um you know if someone is maybe a little
bit more analytical
um maybe using boundaries as a technical
term is is a good uh way to go but I
don't think there's a really hard past
rule exactly how that's going to work
for everyone
thinks do you think it's okay to use
somewhat hyperbolic language in
establishing and maintaining boundaries
so like saying
um
I can't imagine myself being with a
person who does X uh and you're doing X
so so draw the conclusion or saying
something like that's a deal breaker
right deal breaker is kind of a
hyperbolic term should we should we
avoid that or do you think that maybe
that's what's sometimes needed in order
to
to get across to the person sort of like
you know when we talked about this
before when Seneca says the judge is
it's okay for them to appear to be angry
when talking to the the criminal they
shouldn't be angry in handing down the
sentence because then they're going to
sentence them badly but it's okay if
they kind of scare them into not doing
bad action is it okay to like say hey
back off you know in in that sort of way
what do you think I guess it
once again goes back to relationships
and what is the the relationship between
the two what is expected from that
relationship and the way that results in
the best outcomes and
um I guess if we go back to like the
Romantic relationship
there are are definitely going to be on
certain things that and also certain
partners that you do need to say like
this is a hard boundary that it's not
going to be something that's going to
change you know this is a deal breaker
um
and
but really it kind of depends on the
person and especially with the
relationship this is someone that you
are expecting to spend a significant
portion of your life with and
um if you are living in a relationship
in which you are daily filling like your
boundaries are being
transgressed then you should that that's
not a good way to be living with a uh a
person yeah you're being Dishonored or
devalued or taken advantage of yeah yeah
this is not going to lead to a happy
life
yeah that I think that makes perfect
sense so I know we wanted to talk about
a practice to recommend to people to
give give a try to that they can apply
um
all you know do you want to do that and
then I'll I'll mention the book
recommendations at the end and we'll do
our final thought we wrap up the hour
all right so um this is a practice
called uh how can I practice virtue here
and now and so from the enchiridian
um
written by well spoken by Epictetus
written by Aaron
um for every challenge remember the
resources you have within you to cope
with it provoked by the site of a
handsome man or a beautiful woman you
will discover within you the contrary
power of self-restraint faced with pain
you will discover the power of endurance
if you are in insulted you'll discover
patience in time you will grow to be
confident that there is no single
impression that you will not have the
moral means to tolerate
and so so what does that mean
to
um experience and to try to make the
best uh
decisions about how you should act in in
every moment and sometimes this requires
some practice and training and you could
think and call forth uh situations where
you know say if you're in a relationship
and you you call forth the idea of a
beautiful partner that you might want to
um renege on your uh
you know your commitments commitments
yeah
um that you need to actually make sure
that you are making the right choices
for the right reasons
one of the things I like about this
quote is it seems like Epictetus thinks
that we already have if not the
full-blown virtues within us we
certainly have the seeds or or beginning
points of the virtues and that they're
available to all of us as human beings
as part of what it means to be the kind
of things that we are rationalize so
that I I've already got some courage
inside of me I've already got some
justice I've got some wisdom I've got
some heparins but I need to look inside
and say where is it and what does it
look like and how do I apply it in this
situation
now
especially if you are in a a culture in
which you know some of these things that
you you might find to be morally
repugnant are actually Norms it takes
even more work to uh curtail them
there's that and I think a lot of people
have the idea that when when a strong
emotion comes comes there a strong
desire
it's just there and there's nothing they
can do about it they don't have a choice
they have to follow it and then
afterwards they have to pick up the
pieces when they when they've screwed up
and so Epictetus is saying no you
actually do have a choice I mean you can
just follow it along and see how that
works out for you or it's going to be
difficult but you can take this bit of
virtue inside of you and start
practicing it and applying it you know
another thing that he doesn't say here
that I think kind of fits in we have to
figure out what virtue we need in the
situation right
um if it's so the example of like the
potential uh opportunity to cheat you
don't need you don't need courage in
that situation right
because that would say hey yeah take the
chance uh what you need is is temperance
or self-restraint or moderation right or
Justice and once again the virtues are
wisdom Justice courage and temperance
those are the Cardinals yeah yeah should
we should we make a few book
recommendations absolutely final
thoughts
uh
oh go ahead uh Aristotle's the nicomina
ethics wow
um which is um
probably Aristotle's greatest on ethics
and how you should be treating people
Justice and um a lot of his ideas of
golden means
yeah and then Cicero's on duties and on
friendship we've referenced we also
talked about epic betas so the end
gradient and the discourses and then you
brought up Seneca as well his letter to
the killius
um any other or any any last thoughts
because I see where our time is winding
down yeah
um
I think this is a
a very
wide topic and we might come back to it
in the future but um it is I think
really a Paramount to
maintaining good relationships uh not
only with like here I go significant
others but just in general your friends
or family and you know in general life
really even like at work or any any
other social Gathering that you might
find yourself yeah and so to come back
to where we started this is part of the
stoic discipline of action virtue ethics
can be extraordinarily helpful in
learning how to set and identify and
maintain limits and like Dan was just
saying this is an essential part of
being a human being and developing in
our social nature all right thank you
very much and have a lovely day
[Music]